ma
sono pronta per la nuova sfida
vincerò io questa volta
di nuovo
challenge per voi lasciate un mi piace
entro
entro un secondo
un tempo scaduto siete riusciti ad
essere mi piace tra forze cosa è ora
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
se questo video raggiunge i 10 mila
richieste ci sarà un'altra challenge di
via primo round offro un po pitt che non
avete mai visto il bellissimo pronti
e il tuo feed
tastiera è
bellissimo si possono premere i pulsanti
della tastiera guarda
allora che cosa mi offrì per questo
bellissimo pop hit
ma non posso usare quel computer da è un
po pate e pronta sono pronto ad offrirti
tanto per questo compito perché mi piace
molto che cosa lo schiaffino bello
lui ricordo con palermo e infine un
appello come sono mi piace allora ci fai
accetti mi dispiace ma il portiere molto
più raro è bello quindi di più youtube
ha che allora aggiungo fonti non osavo
retto tutto verde detto colore preferito
e ora che ha chiesta colorata che nei
pezzi beh non vedi che i la tastiera un
po vita è molto più rare e bella di
queste cose che ho visto io preda di più
gp
ok allora questo
e l'ultima mia giunta un po pitt gigante
che ne pensi adesso allora cerchi adesso
[Musica]
guarda quanti sono dai secondo accettare
o no gli effetti un po petri citata è
molto bello che aspira e così rara
ne va bene accetto
io prese tutti questi
la tastiera
questa volta io ti offro tre dei nipoti
preferiti
l'avocado poi il gufetto e infine la
grand palais lo e tu cosa di occhio non
è vero non sono i tuoi poveri preferiti
dei preferiti sono il coccodrillo vi
ricordate si era anche l'arco balena sì
ho capito ma post avevo il mio preferito
anche questo caso però non mi interessa
l'avvocato quindi chi offre il cavallino
raro del cavallino è bellissimo
accetti di più le volte di più e berlino
ma stai facendo yoga
ha risposto di sì
allora io ti ho
niente
mi dispiace ma il cavallino più bella di
quei tre poco
3 guarda tre mostre pure va bene
meritando terzo round
offre un bellissimo
e vero o no è carinissimo che bella cosa
grande che sa cosa mi offre per questo
bellissimo colpito anche le zampette e
gli occhi quindi io siccome ho capito
come bisogna comportarsi con te quando
offre queste cose rare
cucinella poi un sensore poi venduto
fragole 2 vuol dire varietà diverse di
rosa per questo più matura mettetelo va
d'ora una morosa colorato e ben due
gelati due gelati turi di quanto io per
due gelati fare qualsiasi cosa
accetti addirittura è offerto 4copy il
cibo che sono i tuoi preferiti
beh in effetti sono tanti profit
attenta però e
ne va bene
a
tutti
attenzione attenzione questa volta io ti
offre robben due pop hit ok e cominciamo
da quello più grande
cuore primo coppi e poi siete pronti
ecco la mia offerta
e tu cosa mi offre e ma che cosa
c'entrano le banali vabbè tu pensi
sempre al cibo hobbit gigante il cuore
mi interessa e molto bello quindi
sia ancora aperta niente scuse dal
partito un attimo e berlioz nel
frattempo sigo ricatto del letto per
dormire
buonanotte merlino anche se non è notte
ancora mahler livio dorme tantissimo io
la farina anche se non è l'arcobaleno è
bellissima nella scala sociale su
qualcuno nei commenti ha scritto non è
una balena è uno squalo a me sembra una
ballerina secondo voi una balena o uno
squalo a questo tappeto e poi
mauro visto che ti piacciono tanto i
fronzoli e poi la maglietta verde oggi
quindi accetti come non vedi che sono
troppo pochi per questo pochi gigante
acqua è vero quasi tentato da accettare
per non sono troppo pochi secondo me
quindi dovresti almeno offrire di più
era bene ti offro largo pinguino
poi il regno lino e poi la farfalla
allora pezzetti allora aspetta che so io
come fai prima vincita di carte colorate
attivo e l'anguria allora aziende penso
proprio che accetterò
che bei e dulko balera
no basta solo la balera e la spezzatura
quinto round di o proposito il girasole
un po pitt cozza poi siccome voglio
tutti i tuoi pop hit
il mio ipad cosa per creativi devi
offrire tantissime cose cosa mi offrì
questo no questo si è pronti dopo testo
e poi hai detto che volevi anche
l'avvocato che significato ha questa
piega il buffetto e poi la prego
l'arcobaleno poi
consigliamo questo vi ricordo questo qui
è da matti che ben si sono questi pochi
si sono
spostate di coppi berlino come pezzi non
devo accettare vero
dei pieno di spiedi mio
gioco due gelati un t rex purgativo
colorato un lecca lecca multicolor e un
lama adesso accetti mi ricordavo che
avresti gruppo click comunque non solo
lo stesso abbastanza per il bio ai
padrini
e allora guarda a lungo questo pop hit
fantasmino è il pozzo che ne pensi
guarda ci sono sono qui funzionanti che
brizzi
adesso beh in effetti così più
interessante l'offerta i più miei anche
fatto vedere che gli esposti ci sono
dentro non come locker potuto nostro
passa dall iphone valori cordate secondo
cui dovrei accettare o no berlino non
può consigliarmi sta dormendo
e va bene
ap
ora tutti i tuoi poppy più vero e beh
tutti i miei coppi in realtà non proprio
tutti tutti è solo questo che ho vinto
però c'è qualche pop hit che come dire
avevo tenuto
[Musica]
nascosto per
ipad
prossimo
ultimo round in questione ci saranno
poche ten credibile inizio io con il pop
il più grande ha
detto
grande sembra un vestito o una coperta
per questo punto mi dovrei offrire tassi
cose allora che cosa vi offre per il
mega diga focus tappeto coperta
legate
bellissimo ci vorranno tante cose per
cambiare questo
berlino nel frattempo continuo a fare
yoga sul letto e devo dire che questo
può fit davvero gigante sta occupando
tutto il tavolo quindi arrotoliamo così
e lo spazio di mettere le altre cose ti
offro tutti i miei altri pochi tutti
quelli che mi sono rimasti ed inquadrato
in confronto a questo quei pochi del
gigante ed in africa non erano troppo
vediamo che soffrirono un frappè grande
un frappè piccolo e poi attenzione
questa è la collezione
io non sono esattamente
245 cockpit che fanno parte di un intera
famiglia di pop pit lane
grazie morda le aler sono tornate
piccola più piccolina cosa è che robert
si sono tutti miei compiti tranne questo
giorno ha scorto qui che mettiamo anche
questo basta ho prodotto ricavi perché
dovrei cambiare il mio magazine
gigantissimo pocket pair dell ananas
assolutamente no voglio chiedere lezione
di un fortunatissimo quello quadrato ed
è grande e piccola tutta la famiglia
ananas
linea di lea era quindi penso alla
cercando di libere atene ok io adesso
sto per raggiungere
questo e mi dispiace perché siamo stati
insieme così poco mi dispiace darti via
ma magari tiri avrò un giorno ok io
metto in ballo ipad
però ci deve essere uno strappo alla
regola o meglio io lo metto in ballo ma
tu devi offrire di più è un po strano
questo scambio c'è praticamente io
riprendere il ipad che ti ho dato x gli
ho già tutti poi pop hit quindi non
sarebbe male come scambio perché i due
titoli cubitali ho già stretti quindi
scambierei semplicemente questo per lei
ha mai detto che devo anche aggiungere
qualcosa in più pezzi che cosa potrei
aggiungere beh visto che stiamo
rimettendo in gioco coste già scambiate
aggiungo
aspetta come aspetto
solo un airpod
che ma io voglio anche l'altro quindi di
più che me ne faccio di uno solo e va
bene anche l'altro
clima anche la custodia come faccio a
ricaricarli sennò di più e
siccome tu prima hai fatto uno strappo
alle regole
io metto anche la custodia
ma voglio io il trio ei sacchetti dico
che io non ho bisogno degli apple io ho
già il mio è il pop personale che è un
modello nuovo 6 si si chiama il bottone
dopo le orecchie innanzitutto che lo
vedi che di fronte e ascolti di più a
chiusura lampo di la vedi
il furgone veramente qui è un po
difficile da reggere quindi ammesso
forse un po più così con un bisogno dei
tuoi f certo non è mai trovato quel
posto di gigante lo metti in gioco
perché è bellissimo in effetti mi
interesserebbe quello se lo metti nello
scambio potrei anche accettare è il miur
fotone non ho visto donne non lo scambio
ed è guarda guarda è molto più grande di
questo cioè guarda ti sembra comparabile
guarda quante piccole queste guardavate
grate questa poi più questa c'è pure la
luce
no no no e va bene io voglio quello
bottone gigante e problema
il tuo preferito
grillo dai di non accettare il sacco di
cose anche year cosa anche se sono
piccoli allora accetti
non lo so cosa devo fare bottone
ma insomma
davvero
e sto parlando wired one ma insomma
sbrigati accetti o no
tale
le regate
ok allora per fortuna è d'accordo e lo
metto in ballo insieme a tutto quello
che ho offerto fino adesso il cambio di
tutti quei bobbit e gli apple suoi
comprerà la custodia è anche il destro e
sinistro tutta quindi a 100 m scambio
allora questi temi ecco il mio bottone e
mi riprendo anche il mio ipad e poi tu
hai tutti questo mi riprendo subito
tutti queste quote
ei non mi tieni anche bello allora ci
abbiamo questi apple bovi nuovi più
tutti questi pop hit questi sono tuoi
c'era anche un anas e anche questa di
più in più il mio bobbit gigante
secondo me sono stata io avere lo
scambio migliore perché ho preso l'ipod
e soprattutto quanto bello brutto il
fondo ne
sono dei buoni ma
che cosa è il bagno
palo smettere subito
non si spegne una
vita rimango su temi così chiedono più
questo mi dispiace per te ma ti ho
fregata lui la il mondo ne scorreggione
io
non ho ormai hutu ad un voto lo scambio
non si può a lui quando comincia
comincia a sparare nel silver basta veti
togli normale che non puzza una volta
più
che
ormai ci posso credere è riuscita a
imbrigliargli
ora mi devo tenere questo coso che sono
in zone
mi vendicherò sappi che mi vendicherò
voi lo so se mi piace se volete ammirare
la vendetta per colpa di evitare mi devo
tenere questo coso
scrivete nei commenti come potrebbe
indicarmi con vitale scrivete
l'occasione commessi anzi no
che pubblica
scrivete nei commenti se volete una
scherzato sia da libera per lo farà
sarà una scoreggia all'altro rilasciamo
44 casi linee su cui cliccare per vedere
da dove altri indicano le cose su quella
che preferite